ON EARTH.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THE RNC KICKS OFF TONIGHT AS I
SAID, IT STOOD IN SHARP CONTRAST
TO THE DOOM AND GLOOM, AMERICA
IS RACIST NIGHTMARE THAT THE DNC
PORTRAYED LAST WEEK.
I FELT AND I HOPE YOU FELT THIS
WAY, IT WAS LIKE A BREATH OF
FRESH AIR.
MAY BE MORE ACCURATELY, IT FELT
LIKE MILLIONS OF PATRIOTIC
HARDWORKING AMERICANS WERE
EXHALING A SIGH OF RELIEF AFTER
A VERY DIFFICULT LAST SIX
MONTHS.
NOW AMERICA ISN’T A COUNTRY THAT
THEY WERE DESCRIBED OF AS IT WAS
LAST WEEK, NO WAY.
TONIGHT WE WERE REMINDED THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS THE MAN WHO
CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THE PRESENT
AND FUTURE AMERICANS OF ALL
RACES, ALL BACKGROUNDS, ALL
CREEDS.
>> WE NEED A PRESIDENT WHO
BELIEVES IN THE AMERICAN DREAM,
LIKE PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
SPEAKER AT THE WHITE HOUSE, MY
FAMILY AND I SAT WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND TOLD HIM ABOUT
MEADOW.
I GOT TO SEE WHO PRESIDENT TRUMP
REALLY IS.
HE’S A GOOD MAN A GREAT
LISTENER.
>> THE PRESIDENT ALSO BUILT THE
MOST EXQUISITE ECONOMY EVER WITH
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND RECORD
HIGH PARTICIPATION IN THE
WORKFORCE.
>> GROWING UP IN THE DEEP SOUTH,
I’VE SEEN RACISM UP CLOSE.
I KNOW WHAT IT IS.
AND IT ISN’T DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: NOTED A FEW WEEKS
AGO, ANDREW POLLOCK AND HERSCHEL
WALKER WILL BE HERE LATER IN THE
HOUR.
THE FIRST NIGHT OF THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION,
I THINK IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ASK A SIMPLE QUESTION: HAS
DONALD TRUMP AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY DONE ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY
BEING REHIRED IN NOVEMBER?
WELL, THE DEMOCRATS SPENT ALL OF
LAST WEEK DURING THEIR DISASTER
OF A VIRTUAL CONVENTION MAKING
THE CASE THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE G.O.P.
HAVE FAILED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> 5 MILLION AMERICANS INFECTED
BY COVID-19.
BY FAR, THE WORST PERFORMANCE OF
ANY NATION ON EARTH.
MORE THAN 50 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT THIS
YEAR.
>> IT’S EIGHT STORM CENTER.
IT’S ONLY CHAOS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS DESTROYING
OUR COUNTRY.
>> THE FUTURE OF OUR DEMOCRACY
IS AT STAKE.
IT’S BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT’S AT
STAKE RIGHT NOW, OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Laura: AN ECHO CHAMBER!
THE DEMOCRATS’ CLAIMS WERE FULL
OF EMOTIONAL RHETORIC.
IT WAS REMARKABLY SHORT ON FACTS
AND POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE REASON IS VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS, IT’S
OBVIOUS THAT NONE OF OUR G7
PEERS IS DOING AS WELL AS THE
UNITED STATES TODAY.
IT’S ALSO CLEAR THAT AMERICA
WOULD DO EVEN BETTER IF THE
DEMOCRATS WHO CONTROL SOME OF
OUR BIGGEST CITIES AND OUR
LARGEST STATES WOULD SPEND LESS
TIME COMPLAINING ABOUT TRUMP AND
MORE TIME LEARNING FROM HIM.
>> WE WILL BUILD MONUMENTS TO
HEROES, NOT BURN DOWN OUR
CITIES.
>> DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO REFUSE
TO DENOUNCE THE MOB DEFUND ORDER
PATROL, AND DEFUND OUR MILITARY.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE CONTROLLED
BOTH PARTS OF
RUNNING THIS PLACE RIGHT INTO
THE GROUND.
ABANDONED BUILDINGS, LIQUOR
STORES IN EVERY CORNER.
>> I FEEL AMERICANS UNDER
ASSAULT FROM SHUTDOWNS, RIOTS,
AND NOW FACING THE TERRIFYING
PROSPECT OF JOE BIDEN COMING
AFTER EVERYTHING WE’VE BUILT.
>> Laura: ALL YEAR WE’VE BEEN
HEARING FROM DEMOCRATS ABOUT HOW
OUR FRIENDS IN CANADA AND
WESTERN EUROPE ARE DOING BETTER
THAN WE ARE.
BUT AGAIN, THE FACTS SAY
OTHERWISE.
LET’S JUST LOOK AT WHAT’S
HAPPENING FOR A MOMENT WITH
COVID.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, THE
NUMBER OF NEW DAILY AND COVID
INFECTIONS JUST HIT A TWO MONTH
LOW.
YOU HEAR THAT LATELY ON THE
OTHER NETWORKS?
EUROPE IS SEEING AN EXPLOSION OF
NEW CASES IN GERMANY, SPAIN,
ITALY, AND ELSEWHERE.
DEMOCRATS WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE
THAT TRUMP’S EXTERNALLY DEFT
HANDLING OF COVID SOMEHOW MADE
AMERICANS MUCH WORSE OFF THAN
OUR FRIENDS IN EUROPE.
>> TOO MANY HARDWORKING FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN CAUGHT ON AN ECONOMIC
TREADMILL.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT AT THE HIGHEST
RATES SINCE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION.
>> BACK IN 2016 WHEN TRUMP
ASKED, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
NOW WE KNOW.
OUR HEALTH CARE, OUR JOBS.
>> Laura: WHAT THEY ARE NOT
TELLING YOU OF COURSE IS HOW
LUCKY WE ARE HOW TRUMP DIDN’T
FOLLOW EUROPE’S LEADER.
THIS B26 PRICES OF COURSE DIDN’T
HURT OUR ECONOMY.
OTHER G7 COMPETITORS ENDED UP
MUCH WORSE OFF.
LOOK AT THE DATA.
THE GDP IN Q2 IN 2020.
WE WERE ALREADY SIGNIFICANT LEAD
RICHER THAN THESE COUNTRIES
BEFORE THE CRISIS BEGAN, OUR PER
CAPITA GDP WAS $30,000 HIGHER
THAN GERMANY, ALMOST DOUBLE
ITALY.
NOW WE ARE MANAGING THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS BETTER THAN ALMOST ALL OF
THEM.
THE GAP BETWEEN US IS LIKELY TO
GROW.
DEMOCRATS ALSO NOT TELLING YOU
THAT OUR RECOVERY IS GOING WAY
BETTER THAN OTHER WESTERN
NATIONS!
TODAY THE S&P 500, NASDAQ HIT
ALL-TIME RECORD HIGHS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THESE INDICES
ARE WORTH MORE TODAY THAN THEY
WERE BEFORE THE VIRUS.
THIS IS GREAT FOR YOUR 401(K)
AND YOUR IRAs ANDS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
MARKETS ARE ONE OF THE BEST WAYS
TO ENGAGE CONSUMER OPTIMISM.
THESE ARE REAL TOUGH PEOPLE
SPENDING REAL MONEY, AND THEY
ARE BETTING ON THE UNITED STATES
UNITED STATES.
>> IN SPITE OF THIS UNBELIEVABLE
OPPOSITION, THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD DO.
TAXES CUT.
REGULATIONS REDUCED.
ECONOMY GROWING.
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN 50 YEARS.
WHO BETTER TO LEAD IN THESE
TIMES THAN A PRESIDENT WHO
ALREADY BUILD THE STRONGEST
ECONOMY OUR COUNTRY HAS EVER
SEEN?
>> WE WANT TO GET AHEAD, NOT
JUST GET BY.
THAT’S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
PROMISED AND THAT’S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVERED.
>> Laura: INVESTORS CLEARLY
LIKE WHAT THEY ARE SEEING WITH
TRUMP AND AFTER HEARING
DEMOCRATS LAY OUT THEIR
DISASTROUS DESIGNS FOR THE
ECONOMY LAST WEEK, WHO CAN BLAME
THEM?
>> CANCELING STUDENT LOAN
DEBT...
>> JOE WOULD ROLL BACK THE TAX
CUT THAT I GOT SO WEAK AND FUN
THINGS OUR WHOLE COUNTRY NEEDS.
WE SUPPORT BILLIONS INTO PRIVATE
BUSINESSES.
THERE SHOULD BE TEN SOLYNDRAS,
THERE SHOULD BE TEN FAILED
INVESTMENTS.>> I WOULD LISTEN TO
SCIENTISTS.
>> Laura: HE SAID THAT AFTER
THE DNC.
OF COURSE HE’D SHUT IT DOWN.
YOU CAN SEE WHY THE DEMOCRATS
WERE AFRAID TO REALLY GET INTO
THE NITTY-GRITTY OF POLICY.
FOR FOUR YEARS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE REPUBLICANS HAVE PROVEN
THAT THEIR POLICIES WORK BETTER
THAN ANYTHING THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TO OFFER.
THEIR FAITH AND FREEDOMS, THE
RULE OF LAW WORKS BETTER THAN
THE CHAOS WE SEE TONIGHT IN
CERTAIN BLUE CITIES.
WE WILL GET TO WISCONSIN IN A
BIT.
OF COURSE, THE STRICT
REGULATIONS, HIGH TAXES THAT
STIFLE INNOVATION IN PLACES LIKE
CANADA, EUROPE, AND JAPAN.
THE DEMOCRATS DIDN’T TALK ABOUT
POLICIES LAST WEEK, NOT REALLY.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANY IDEAS THAT
WOULD MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
IT’S JUST RHETORIC AND RHETORIC
AND MORE RHETORIC.
IT WOULD BE A TERRIBLE ERROR FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO CHANGE
COURSE.
TO EMULATE THE DISASTERS THAT
ARE CAUSING SO MUCH TROUBLE IN
NEW YORK AND ELSEWHERE.
LET’S KEEP ON THE PATH THAT’S
WORKING.
LET’S VOTE FOR TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICANS.
KEEP AMERICA GREAT?
HOW ABOUT MAKE AMERICA EVEN
BETTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER
YEAR?
AND THAT MEANS THAT AMERICA IS